everything that we say we want
is because of how we think we're going
to feel when we get it
how do you define success
my definition of success has changed
over the last two years and
i would not be surprised if it changed
again in the next coming years i think
that
for the last
10 years i really define success
by
the projects i was booking and the money
i was making
and
once i got those things that i desired
then i realized
wait a minute
i really just want to be happy
not that some of those things didn't
make me happy but
now i'm really
chasing for lack of a better word
what makes me happy
and
and that's to me more important i think
that
i'm still
weaving
into my you know one of my coaches was
like oh so you say that's what or maybe
my therapist said this you say that
success is just about what makes you
happy but you're still kind of
living in this world where you want to
make a certain amount of money and you
want to book certain projects and and so
i think that i have one foot in that
world and one foot in this world but for
me
it's so much more about
being happy
and helping people
and so i'm i'm trying to
refocus my energy
on that because i think it's really easy
to get caught up especially in the
social media world where we're comparing
ourselves to other people all the time
and what their lives look like and where
they're spending their money and what
projects you know i think um
you know a lot of my actor clients we
talk about how
their least favorite question ever is
have i seen you in anything or are you
working on anything now
people feel very insecure about that
question and so
i just you know
i myself have gotten very caught up in
what projects i'm working on so that i
can tell other people and then i will be
perceived as successful and being
perceived as successful is more
important than how i actually feel
doing these things and so
um
so now i'm just trying to let go of that
and focus on
what makes me happy like i think that
you know it's like if we look back at
our lives i don't know i would rather be
happy and doing things that feel good
and excite me than constantly worrying
about trying to compare myself to others
and what it looks like to other people
what do you think about the fact that
that's a great place to be in but some
people might need to have
kissed the ring so to speak and then
realize you know what it wasn't that
great and i actually just want to be
happy but they needed that
experience to know i actually was up
here for a little bit and i decided
i wasn't happy but i needed to know what
that felt like
yeah i think that
we all are on our own journey we all are
on our own path you know if i had to
experience that to learn this lesson
it's not even necessarily a lesson it's
just a redirect for myself
um
and so
i don't think there's anything wrong
with like some people just have to live
out their journey and live out their own
experiences than to decide what they
want you know i think that's what we're
always collecting data
based on how we feel so everything that
we do we're collecting data and then
we're re-evaluating so i think that's
totally okay but what i do
sort of direct people in my book is to
and again this is something that i feel
like that i've been working on is to
stop setting goals that are based on
validation
right so
try to at least start chasing the joy
because i think that the all those
things that you think you want they're
going to come anyway right you can be
happy and get all those things but we
don't necessarily always know why we
want those things and so i think it is
important to take a look at like well
why do i want that you know like i
remember i have a dream of buying a
house it used to be in the hills but now
i want one in the palisades or you know
with ocean view as opposed to city view
and i remember someone said to me oh do
you want that because of how it'll look
and i said oh my gosh no
that that's not part of this dream for
me at all i want it because i have
family back on the east coast and i want
rooms for them to come visit for
extended periods of time so that i can
be you know i'm very close with my
family and i hate that they're so far
away and i don't get to see them very
often
um and i'm also very sensitive to my
surroundings that i want surroundings
that inspire me and excite me
and so it's really what it's about and
so
i think yeah i think
if you're feeling like well i want the
money or i want
the accolades
it's just about getting really
honest with yourself about why you want
those things
everything that we say we want
is because of how we think we're going
to feel when we get it
so if you you know if you want an oscar
why why do what do you think you're
going to feel when you get that oscar
and and i think that if you can break
down those feelings it's more important
to sort of chase those feelings or to
try to feel those now
than necessarily the the label that you
think is going to give you those
feelings
um if that makes sense so i think you
know like i said in my book it's really
about like set any goal that you want
there's nothing wrong with any of them
um
but if you're chasing them for
validation to make you feel good to make
you feel more worthy or more deserved
deserved deserve it
um
it probably isn't going to feel the way
that you
think it's going to feel it's not going
to solve the inner problem right like
none of the external things that we
create for ourselves or that we get
aren't going to are never going to solve
an internal
problem
i think most of this is is validation
from others or self-validation
validation from others
you think that matters more to most
people i think a lot i think a lot of us
make decisions based on
how others will perceive it
how like for example
everyone and their mother in this
industry says that they want to work on
netflix you know on a netflix project
and you know there might be some
like there might be some reasons behind
that
in the terms of well they do great work
you know they they tell complex stories
and i'm interested in the stories that
they're telling
but a lot of people especially the
actors that i work with or the directors
the writers
they say they want netflix because
netflix is a huge well-known entity
right now
and if they book something netflix they
can then post it on social media or they
can tell people hey i booked a netflix
show
and that makes them feel successful
because they're perceived as successful
because it's a network or streamer that
everybody knows
right but
what if what was really important to you
that you booked a project that told a
meaningful story
that impacted people's lives and that
was really fun to create and it felt
really great like you were working with
great people collaborating with great
people and the whole experience just
felt good well what if you could get
that experience
at abc
or on hulu or you know or another
smaller now you know because i talk
about one of my best experiences in
hollywood was a show that was on abc
family
which is now free form you know and i
don't think many people
are like i want to work on freeform like
everyone's like i want to work on
netflix you know it's not maybe as sexy
maybe they don't have quite as many
viewers but it was the most fun i ever
had
on a show and we were telling a
meaningful story and there were really
amazing crew and cast members
it was just a really good experience
so
yeah i think that it's this is a long
way to say i i think it is about chasing
validation from others and how we are
perceived by others
and does that go back to sort of that
boxes thing that you said like being in
la you you think that there's these
certain rules in these boxes and it's
the same thing about like oh
oh you're just doing the um the score
network
i've never heard of it yeah oh okay yeah
no but if you were somewhere else
oh wow you're on a tv show how cool
right but here there's these levels
right the hierarchy yeah yeah i i don't
know if it's necessary i guess the box
is in a way where you're like boxing
yourself into what your dream has to
look like like my dream has to look like
me working for netflix um so i guess in
a way but i do think yeah that people
don't realize
that it's probably going to be a more
enjoyable experience if you
intentionally try to create
a good experience for yourself you know
like a show that you love working on
that you're doing meaningful work then
whatever the label of the network or the
studio is you know because you know look
like i've i've known series regulars who
have quit
and who just like after a few seasons
weren't feeling fulfilled anymore it
wasn't like a story they felt like was
meaningful in their lives you know and
so
that happens you know like you might get
the thing that you think you want like
you might get netflix
and then it not be a good experience i'm
not trying to put that out there i'm
sure like there's a lot of amazing
experiences on netflix but my point is
like get clear about how you want the
experience to feel and what you want the
experience to look like like i say in my
book like write make a list of
everything that you want in the next
project you want to book or whatever
goal you're working towards write the
list of everything that everything you
think netflix is going to give you
right write down everything you think
it's going to give you and then
take away netflix at the top
and then but still but still chase your
list
right so you're still really going after
what you truly want
but you're allowing it to look however
it looks
how do you help people with the part of
success where they want what other
people have
i mean that is
happening all the time and i have
found myself
getting caught up in that too you know i
think that
when people post things on social media
i think that's like really a lot of
where it comes from as opposed to seeing
it in actual real life i think that when
we see somebody's highlight reel on
social media
we are
putting a whole story behind that post
about what it means and how it must feel
for them to have what that thing
right so
if somebody posts a picture of
themselves
driving a porsche you know a fan's very
fancy car
and they're smiling in it and they're
like yeah you know they look cool
you might then create this whole story
about
what that means for that person and how
their life must be so amazing and it
must feel so good for them and wow they
have so much money and we create this
whole narrative about what it means when
we see
them having this thing and we're like
well we want those feelings i i want to
feel
financially stable i want to feel
wealthy i want to
um feel excited about a new purchase i
want to have a car like that right so we
we
think that they're feeling a certain way
when they have something
and then we want to feel that way and so
we think
the way we feel it is to try to get the
same thing they have
and it's so easy to get caught up in
whatever we think
you know
people are
or whatever we're seeing people have you
know even if it's a a booking you know
if you book a job or you have an
audition or something you know i think
that
if you see someone post online that
um i'm trying to think of something that
maybe i've thought i wanted but i didn't
actually want like
like
for example one of my clients
said you know what they're an actor and
they were like you know what
every actor wants to be series regular
they think it's like hitting the lottery
you know financial lottery because it's
it's a lot of money and it's consistent
work
and
one of my clients was like you know what
i don't think i want to be serious
regular at this time in my life like
because you usually have to wake up at
like four in the morning you know you're
there all day it's a very long day you
have to wake she's like i don't know if
i really i kind of like waking up at
eight o'clock and said you know i don't
know if that's really what i want in my
life right now
so she had to you know get honest about
wait a minute what makes me happy what
would make me happy now
so i think social media plays a big role
in it but but it's really what we decide
it means
right what we decide it means that this
person booked this project or has this
opportunity
we also don't know the truth about what
it means to that person or what they're
really feeling on the other side of it
you know maybe
they're like posting i i had this
amazing audition for this for netflix
wow i'm so lucky i have such a great
life
but really they're feeling like maybe it
was like a
two-line role and it was something that
they're not actually excited about but
they're trying to tell the world that
they had this netflix audition and then
people that see it are like oh man they
have this great life they're getting
these netflix auditions and then we
create the story about what we think
they're feeling or what you know
so
i think it comes down to
what are the feelings you want to feel
when you get the thing you want
and stop assuming that every single
person who has something feels that
exact way because i think we're
attaching those feelings to what other
people have
you